Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to use this
new AI research work to create
absolutely magical videos almost out of
thin air. Like this one. And this one. Yes,
with this new work, we can all become
movie directors. Sort of. Loving it.
Now, everyone knows that modern AI techniques are
already capable of text to image, that is taking a
piece of text and creating a picture out of it.
What fewer people know, but many of you Fellow
Scholars definitely know is that
text to video is now also possible.
However, I bet that you didn’t know about
today’s paper! So, what is this about? Well,
whenever I use these systems, I always
feel myself yearning for more artistic
control. I want to specify the pose
for these characters. The framing too,
what should be visible, where the characters
and objects are. And more. That would be lovely.
So, in this new paper scientists had
an excellent question - why not give
more information to the AI for these videos?
And that is an excellent question. You see,
this new technique allows us to show
the AI exactly what we are looking
for by performing it ourselves
and giving it that as an input.
It goes the following way: imagine that we would
like to have a video of an astronaut surfing,
but obviously, that’s not us. So, first, we record
ourselves surfing, give this video to the AI,
add a text prompt that now an astronaut
should be surfing, and, I am very excited,
let’s see. Oh yes, that is so cool! And, if
we wish to reimagine what this scene would
look like if we were surfing in the desert, not a
problem. Or, we can also think bigger, and ask for
a surfing sloth instead. Look at that. This sloth
is having the time of his life. And I particularly
like this example because this almost feels like
a motion capture video where we just provide the
movement for some other character. And all this
with just one video and one text prompt. Wow.
Now wait, this new work also gives us a
ton more tools to play with. For instance,
if we have a video of a bear playing a guitar, a
common occurrence, we can also ask it to make it a
little more artistic. And if we have a cat, we can
make it two, add cowboy hats, or even remove that
hat and have it synthesize a similar video. I also
loved this example. A simple video of this good
boy running in the garden, and we can use it as
the blueprint for our text to image ideas. Look,
it has been changed to a corgi and it is
now in a different environment, or a lion,
or whatever we can imagine. So I hear you asking
- what is so cool about this example? Well,
imagine if we are very picky with the kind of
footage we want to synthesize, we would have to
write in text what the pace, direction and the
exact angle should the walking take place in.
But this paper says, none of that is required,
just show the AI what you wish to see. So good.
Now, this is not the first paper to attempt
this, so let’s see what previous methods
were made of. Oh boy. Look. This is
the Video Diffusion Models paper,
VDM in short, and the quality of
the outputs is not the greatest,
but there is an even bigger problem. What is the
problem? Well, temporal coherence. Each adjacent
frame seems so different, for instance,
the color of the clothing is different,
each time. If we weave these together into a
video, we will get a ton of flickering. Not good.
So, let’s see the new method. Whoa. This
is so much better. Let’s do another one of
these fun comparisons. Let’s
see….yes this is CogVideo,
another earlier technique. The prompt is “a cat
running on a single-plank bridge, comic style”.
Wow, I don’t know about this one. Look. I
am not sure if this is a cat, not sure if
this is a bridge, and I am not sure if this is
in a comic style. The rest is fine though. So,
let’s see the new one. Wow. This is
incredible improvement in just…wait,
actually, in how long exactly? When were these
two previous works published? Is this new work
10 years of progress? No-no, not at all. And this
is the part where I fell of the chair when reading
this paper. Hold on to your papers, because
both of these previous works were published
less then a year before this new one. My goodness.
That is amazing progress in just a few months.
Now, we are experienced Fellow Scholars over
here, so we are also looking for a little more
details regarding the old vs new technique.
So let’s dig a little deeper…and, this is
a human evaluation on a set of 32 videos,
and are you seeing what I am seeing? This
is one of the biggest improvements in just
a few months that I have ever seen. Almost
everyone favored the new one. Bravo! And just
imagine what we will be able to do just a couple
more papers down the line. Who knows, we all might
become movie directors. What a time to be alive!
So, what do you think? What would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!